[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis guten abend und herzlich
willkommen die spannenden wettkämpfe bei
den paralympics gleich von norbert
lehmann
der anschlag am flughafen in kabul und
seine folgen unser großes thema heute
verzweiflung in afghanistan nach dem
anschlag gestern wächst die angst vor
weiteren attacken die letzten
bundeswehrsoldaten werden am abend in
deutschland zurückerwartet
union unter druck vier wochen vor der
bundestagswahl liegen cdu csu und spd im
politbarometer gleichauf und
sensationen tokio in deutschlands
rollstuhlbasketballer bezwingen bei den
paralympics weltmeister großbritannien
hoch gefährlich sei es weiterhin am
flughafen von kabul so die einschätzung
nicht nur aus dem auswärtigen amt nach
der verheerenden explosion gestern
inmitten tausender verzweifelter
menschen sprengte sich laut us
verteidigungsministerium ein
selbstmordattentäter in die luft am gate
dem östlichen zugangstor zum flughafen
kurz danach fielen schüsse nach
unbestätigten medienberichten wurden
mindestens 100 menschen getötet mehr als
160 verletzt lück weiter berichtet sie
sind mit dem leben davon gekommen in den
krankenhäusern kabuls werden dutzende
verletzte versorgt die sich gestern in
der nähe des anschlags aufhören
die explosion hat mich in den
abwasserkanal gesprochen da sagen sie
stimmten
den ganzen tag über wurden särge
verkäufern abtransportiert die das
attentat nicht überlebt haben wie vor
den krankenhäusern haaren verzweifelte
angehörige aus mein mann liegt der
kritischen zustand auf der
intensivstation hier ist sehr schwer
verletzt den bauch der rücken die beine
alles in schwerin zu standen
am flughafen tor wo ein
selbstmordattentäter gestern so viele
menschen grausam ermordete herrscht
heute stille im netz bekannte sich ein
ableger des selbsternannten islamischen
staates zu dem anschlag die es
terroristen hatten schon in der
vergangenheit zahlreiche blutige
anschläge auf schulen und krankenhäuser
in afghanistan verübt sie bekämpfen auch
die radikal islamischen taliban denen
sie vorwerfen kompromisse mit den usa
eingegangen zu sein ein taliban-sprecher
erklärte die verantwortung für den
anschlag gegen die usa und deren
verbündete werden sie haben die menschen
zur ausreise ermuntert und sie bewachen
den gesperrten flughafen für uns ist es
sehr schwer 10.000 menschen vor dem
flughafen zu kontrollieren das ist ein
großes problem
die meisten staaten haben inzwischen die
evakuierungsflüge eingestellt mehr als
5300 menschen flug die bundeswehr aus
kabul nach taschkent 300 deutsche halten
sich aber noch in afghanistan auf sie
konnten später ausreisen so die
zusicherung der taliban wenn der
linienflugbetrieb in kabul wieder
aufgenommen werden
darüber verhandelt die türkische
regierung derzeit mit den taliban der
ausgang ist ungewiss auch eine ausreise
über den landweg wird erwogen die
grenzen wie ich ihr nach pakistan sind
allerdings von den taliban bewacht
tausende afghanen drängen sich seit
tagen an den übergängen in der hoffnung
das land doch noch verlassen zu können
und glück hat ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet
auf der einen seite die terror miliz es
die offenbar hinter dem anschlag gestern
steckt auf der anderen seite ja die
radikalislamischen taliban die in
afghanistan die macht übernommen haben
droht jetzt ein bürgerkrieg
also ganz ausgeschlossen ist dass leider
nicht beide terrorgruppen es und taliban
hatten bislang immer einen gemeinsamen
feind nämlich die afghanische regierung
und die internationale militärkoalition
die diese regierung gestützt hat jetzt
sind die taliban an der macht und das
heißt für den esc haben einen neuen
hauptgegner sie werden jetzt alles daran
setzen dieses land zu destabilisieren
das war bisher ihre taktik das wird auch
künftig ihre taktik sein sie sind zwar
nach experten schätzungen etwa nur 1500
kämpfer in afghanistan aber sie haben in
der vergangenheit schon bewiesen dass
sie damit enorm viel terror verbreiten
können im land die methode ist immer die
gleiche sie suchen sich sehr schwache
ziele je feiger und hinterhältiger der
anschlag desto besser schulen
krankenhäuser
hilfsorganisationen
wehrlose dorfbewohner das sind ihre
ziele möglichst viel blutvergießen damit
panik und die stabilisierung schaffen
und damit auch zeigen dass die taliban
offensichtlich das heft des handelns
nicht in der hand haben also für die
nächsten monate wenn die taliban das
nicht in den griff bekommen falls das
nichts gutes vielen dank für diese
einschätzung teilt auch
die usa machen den es für das
selbstmordattentat verantwortlich bei
dem auch 13 us soldaten getötet wurden
us präsident biden kündigte vergeltung
an es steht ohnehin innenpolitisch stark
unter druck angesichts des chaotischen
und gefährlichen abzuges bis dienstag
wollen die usa den einsatz beenden
claudia bates über die schwersten
verluste der us truppen in afghanistan
seit jahren
steigen für die toten der präsident
angeschlagen in jeder hinsicht wieder
einmal braucht es heldengeschichten um
soldaten tode zu rechtfertigen
diese soldaten die ihr leben gegeben
haben sind es ist ein abgegriffenes wort
aber es stimmt sind helden die in einer
gefährlichen und selbstlosen mission ihr
leben gegeben haben um andere leben zu
retten
doch in der sache bleibt beiden glasklar
die mission läuft weiter wie geplant wer
übernimmt die verantwortung der krieg
muss beendet werden aber terroristen
weiterhin gejagt
an die die diesen angriff ausgeführt
haben und alle die amerika schaden
wollen wir werden nicht vergeben wir
werden nicht vergessen wir werden euch
jagen und ihr werdet dafür bezahlen
und während in der washingtoner sonne
die flaggen auf halbmast wehen werden
dem pentagon pläne entworfen für den
gegenschlag
anti-terror-kampf aus der ferne ein
irrglaube meinen experten
wir werden wieder reingehen müssen um
den es zu kriegen und auch wenn sich al
qaida in afghanistan wieder formiert und
das werden sie wir können ein
schlachtfeld verlassen aber nicht den
krieg gegen den terrorismus
die opposition spricht von inkompetenz
der präsident spricht von
standhaftigkeit die evakuierung aus
kabul geht weiter flieger um flieger um
flieger
die bundeswehr hat ihren rettungseinsatz
in afghanistan ja bereits beendet
innerhalb der nächsten stunde soll die
maschine auf dem luftwaffenstützpunkt in
niedersächsischen wunstorf landen unter
labbadia aus unserem hauptstadtstudio
wie wird die ankunft der soldatinnen und
soldaten ablaufen also nach jetziger
planung wird das eine ganz schlichte
zeremonie sind zwei maschinen die dort
landen sollen und mit an bord ist jetzt
schon die verteidigungsministerin
annegret kramp karrenbauer zusammen mit
der wehrbeauftragten des bundestages und
dem generalinspekteur der bundeswehr
sie haben gemeinsam die einsatzkräfte in
taschkent abgeholt fliegen jetzt mit
ihnen zurück und das soll dann nach der
landung eine eine kurze zeremonie geben
mit grußworten an die anwesenden also
relativ sachlich und nüchtern aber eine
würdigung tatsächlich von politischer
seite für immerhin den größten
evakuierungseinsatz der bundeswehr es
ist jetzt so gleich auch der abschluss
von 20 jahren afghanistan-einsatz ein
bedrückendes ende wie wir jetzt eben in
den letzten tagen und wochen sehen
mussten über das auch alle immer noch
sehr bestürzt sind es bleiben viele
fragen offen und deswegen verbietet sich
hier auch eine größere zeremonie bei der
rückkehr der letzten einsatzkräfte
denn immerhin sehen wir jetzt den
zerfall von ordnung und sicherheit in
afghanistan
wir sehen einen großen ansehen an einen
großen ansehensverlust der westlichen
streitkräfte und es ist immer noch
völlig offen wie das schicksal der
zurückgebliebenen in afghanistan
aussehen wird das auswärtige amt spricht
von 300 deutschen die noch dort sind und
noch nicht raus geholt werden konnten
und mindestens 10.000 afghanischen orts
kräften und anderen menschen denen man
die ausreise versprochen hat also da
wird sich jetzt noch die frage stellen
wie soll das ganze noch zu ende geführt
werden aussenminister heiko maas will ja
am wochenende aufbrechen zu einer reise
in die nachbarländer um dort dafür zu
werben um für unterstützung zu werben um
diese menschen noch raus zu bekommen
aber momentan stehen vor allem fragen im
raum auch die frage welche lehren zieht
man aus diesem einsatz zum beispiel auch
für andere auslandseinsätze der
bundeswehr
amtlich mali wird hier von kritikern
schon genannt dankeschön chacón talabani
sobald die bundeswehrmaschine in
deutschland landen können sie das mit
zdf heute live verfolgen zu finden
online auf zdf heute und in unserer app
dort halten wir sie immer auf dem
laufenden mit vielen hintergründen und
den aktuellen entwicklungen der lage in
afghanistan
der bundeswehreinsatz in afghanistan
soll auch noch politisch aufgearbeitet
werden ein untersuchungsausschuss ist im
gespräch wie sehen die bürger innen in
deutschland den einsatz dazu haben wir
ein zdf politbarometer und die neuen
zahlen hat matthias fornoff für sie
guten abmarschieren abend hallo
was haben die befragten gesagt halten
sie den militäreinsatz gegen die taliban
seit 2001 grundsätzlich für richtig ja
oder nein na ja die deutschen sind da
total gespalten die eine hälfte findet
dass der militäreinsatz grundsätzlich
richtig war die andere hälfte hält ihn
für einen fehler aber eine mehrheit
meint dass man mehr tun müsste um die
afghanischen ortskräfte zurückzuholen
schauen wir doch mal auf das hauptthema
dieses zdf politbarometers das ist die
bundestagswahl als erstes blick auf die
kanzlerkandidaten und die
kanzlerkandidatin wer kommt da am besten
an scholz von der spd laschet von union
oder die grüneberg wir haben gefragt wer
ist als kanzler oder kanzlerin geeignet
nur ein viertel hält armin laschet für
geeignet fast zwei drittel aber trauen
olaf scholz dass kanzler am zug annalena
baerbock dagegen ist nicht geeignet das
sagen knapp drei viertel der befragten
entsprechend klar führt scholz auch bei
der frage wie man am liebsten als
kanzler hätte scholz gilt mit großem
vorsprung als glaubwürdiger und die
deutschen sprechen ihm auch den meisten
sachverstand zu auch bei den
sympathiewerten liegt scholz klar vorn
schauen wir mal ist es auf die parteien
da tut sich ja auch einiges an einen
monat vor der bundestagswahl wir sind da
die zahlen aber jetzt berühre auf die
zielgerade im wahlkampf gehen da gibt es
eine menge bewegung in der
parteienlandschaft wenn am sonntag
bundestagswahl wäre käme die union auf
22 prozent minus 4 punkte im vergleich
zur umfrage vor zwei wochen ihr
schlechtester wert jemals im
politbarometer die spd klettert auf 22
prozent plus 3 ihr bester wert seit fast
vier jahren afg unverändert 11 prozent
fdp 10 linke 6 beide minus 1 grüne 20
prozent plus 1 kein zweierbündnis hätte
demnach eine mehrheit aber verschiedene
dreier koalitionen darunter erstmals
seit mai auch wieder rot grün rot
fast 90 prozent sagen allerdings es ist
noch nicht klar wer die wahl gewinnen
wird und so bleibt es vor allem eins
spannend und sie werden das weiter für
uns beobachten bis zur bundestagswahl
haben wir jede woche ein neues zdf
ergometer führen dankbar das war noch
und ausführlich können sie das
zdf-politbarometer im heute journal
sehen sowie natürlich jederzeit in der
zdf- heute- app und wir haben es eben
gehört union und spd also gleich auf und
das nachdem cdu csu anfang des jahres im
zdf-politbarometer noch bei 37 prozent
lagen angesichts dieses absturzes in den
umfragen rotes ordentlich in den beiden
schwesterparteien viele fragen sich ob
laschet der richtige kanzlerkandidat ist
patricia wiedemeier berichtet
fährt man in diesen tagen durch berlin
auf den plakaten der spd hier
kanzlerkandidat olaf scholz und immer
wieder olaf scholz auf den plakaten der
union sucht man vergebens den
kanzlerkandidaten mit armin laschet wird
selten geworden kein wunder die
umfragewerte für laschet und damit für
die union brechen ein ein wechsel an der
spitze wird jedoch ausgeschlossen armin
laschet ist der kanzlerkandidat der
union und er ist der richtige und am
ende geht es ja auch um mehr als nur
einen kanzlerkandidaten es geht um ein
gesamtpaket am ende des tages wählen die
menschen ja auch parteien parteien sind
mehr als nur die spitzenkandidaten bis
zur wahl also weniger auf den kandidaten
setzen mehr auf die partei so das motto
laschet müsse jetzt ein regierungsteam
präsentieren fordert der saarländische
ministerpräsident zitat wir müssen
endlich zeigen wofür die union steht und
mit wem wir neben dem kanzlerkandidaten
die zukunft des landes prägen wollen
armin laschet übt sich derweil im spagat
einerseits ist er kanzlerkandidat
andererseits entschlossen handeln der
landesvater beim thema fluthilfe ich
finde man muss seiner dienstpflicht als
regierungschef als ministerpräsident
auch in zeiten von wahlkämpfen
nachkommen und ich habe auch die absicht
dies durchzuhalten ganz anders natürlich
die stimmung bei der spd
wahlkampfauftakt der berliner spd heute
nachmittag das ist jetzt so hoch
gekommen sind mal von 13 auf 23 ist
aufwand ich glaube nicht dass armin
laschet das was er jetzt vor die wand
gefahren hat wieder rausholen kann und
wer aber glaube ich wird auch nicht mehr
kanzlerin olaf scholz macht weiter
wahlkampf freut sich über steigende
beliebtheitswerte es ist schön wie sich
die umfragen entwickeln es ist berührend
und ich sage das sehr sehr klar zu sehen
wie viele bürgerinnen und bürger mir
zutrauen der nächste kanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland zu sein es
ist und bleibt spannend union und spd
derzeit gleichauf kurz hinter ihnen die
grünen wer hier im kanzleramt einziehen
wird alles noch offen
während die union also zittert ob sie
den nächsten kanzler stellen kann muss
die linkspartei sogar um den
wiedereinzug in den bundestag bangen 6
prozent zdf politbarometer bisher
profitiert die linke nicht davon dass
sie als einzige partei immer schon gegen
den afghanistan einsatz war heike
slansky über den wahlkampfauftakt in
rostock
rostock universitätsplatz eigentlich ein
heimspiel für den pragmatiker dietmar
bartsch der hier seinen wahlkreis hat er
träumt von einem mitte-links-bündnis und
einem zweistelligen wahlergebnis doch
aktuell steht die linke gefährlich nah
an der fünf-prozent-hürde zufalls
umfrage
die armut bekämpfen will die
arbeitslosigkeit bekämpfen will dann
würde ich sagen ja
sollten viel mehr leute die linke wählen
es gibt immer mehr parteien immer mehr
leute die unterschiedliche meinungen
haben uns einfach auch schwierig
komplett den geist eines menschen zu
treffen die linke kämpft für mehr
soziale gerechtigkeit höhere steuern für
wohlhabende
mindestrente und mieten deckel doch
außenpolitisch steht sie im abseits
zuletzt beim rettungseinsatz der
bundeswehr in afghanistan
wenn jetzt gesagt wird die linke hat
sich enthalten bei der abstimmung ja
haben wir und zwar aus gutem grund und
wenn die spd jetzt sagt die linke ist
nicht regierungsfähig
20 jahre rot grün hat die soldaten in
den einsatz geschickt einen
richtungswechsel fordert die linke
umverteilen sozial und klimagerechte
slogan wir kämpfen für einen
politikwechsel der so dringend notwendig
ist für soziale gerechtigkeit für
klimaschutz und für eine friedliche
außenpolitik
wahlkampfauftakt der linken das
interesse mäßig noch gut vier wochen bis
zur bundestagswahl für die linke auch
ein kampf ums überleben
gute nachrichten für alle die urlaub
machen wollen spanien wird von der liste
der hochrisiko gebiete gestrichen ebenso
wie der großraum von portugals
hauptstadt lissabon
damit entfällt ab sonntag die quarantäne
pflicht für alle auch für die
reiserückkehrer innen die noch nicht
geimpft oder genesen sind blicken wir
auf die korona zahlen für deutschland
das robert koch institut meldet 12.000
29 neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind
2749 mehr als vor einer woche 14
menschen starben im zusammenhang mit
cody 19 binnen eines tages die sieben
tage incidents liegt bei 70,3
österreichs ex vize kanzler strache ist
wegen bestechlichkeit schuldig
gesprochen worden das landgericht wien
verurteilte ihn zu 15 monaten haft auf
bewährung
in dem fall ging es um die frage ob
strache sich für eine gesetzesänderung
eingesetzt hatte durch die ein
befreundeter betreiber einer
privatklinik profitierte im gegenzug
sollen parteispenden an die
rechtsgerichtete fpö geflossen sein das
urteil ist noch nicht rechtskräftig
zu wenig sonne und zu nass auch dieses
jahr fällt die ernte in deutschland
unterdurchschnittlich aus der
bauernverband rechnet dann getreide mit
einem minus von 2 prozent gegenüber dem
vorjahr das schlechte wetter habe das
wachstum und die ernte behindert mais
und gemüse dagegen hätten von dem vielen
regen profitiert außerdem erfreulich für
die bauern preise am agrarmarkt sind
nach angaben des verbandes gestiegen
und wir kommen wieder zum paralympics in
tokio norbert unter die lenz deutschland
erreicht es gibt ja allerdings die
frauen die haben das viertelfinale
erreicht durch den sieg gegen
großbritannien und mit den briten hatten
es auch die männer heute zu tun nach der
knappen niederlage gestern gegen die usa
heute ein sensationeller sieg gegen den
weltmeister und er war auch dringend
notwendig
davon hatten sie alle geträumt es
tatsächlich geschafft zu haben war
überwältigend 71 59 gegen beeindruckte
weltmeister aus großbritannien tommy
böhmes treffsicherheit hatte die
favoriten zermürbt 27 punkte steuerte
der mann aus wetzlar zum triumph bei
auch antrieb enix ausbeute mit 17
punkten höchst beachtlich sowie die
leistung des gesamten teams das mit viel
selbstvertrauen ins morgige gruppenspiel
gegen australien geht
und auch im tischtennis zeigt das
deutsche team topleistungen valentin
baus und thomas schmidberger haben ihre
viertelfinals gewonnen und damit eine
medaille sicher
bundesbürgern london
schmidberger also eine weitere
paralympics medaille einplanen nach
einem klaren dreisatzsieg gegen den
chinesen jumping zog der
weltranglisten-zweite ins morgige
halbfinale ein und will dort den
finaleinzug schaffen das endspiel hat
auch valentin baus im blick in nur 18
minuten fertigte der
silbermedaillengewinner von rio den
franzosen nicolas
klar in drei sätzen ab bereits morgen
geht es im halbfinale auch für ihn darum
den traum vom paralympics gold zu
sichern
bundestrainer hansi flick hat den 26
köpfigen kader für die wm quali spiele
der dfb-elf bekannt gegeben mit marco
reus von borussia dortmund gibt es einen
prominenten rückkehrer ins team er soll
die offensive verstärken wie auch der 19
jährige carina die chemie von rb
salzburg einer der drei neulinge im team
david raum von der tsg hoffenheim und
u21-nationalspieler nico flotter weg von
sc freiburg sind als defensivspieler
auch erstmals dabei
und cristiano ronaldo steht auch im
kader aber leider nicht mit dem des dfb
sondern in dem von manchester also
schauen wir aus wochenende das wird eher
herbstlich kühl mit regenschauern und
auch mal gewittern aber nächste woche
scheint sich daran etwas zu ändern was
wie wo sagt ihnen gleich katja horneffer
um 22 uhr können sie hier das heute
journal sehen mit claus kleber auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend tief nick ist auch wieder so
ein tief das sich kaum von der stelle
gehört so können am nordrand von
erzgebirge oder harz oder auch am
alpenrand bis sonntagabend noch einmal
50 liter regen pro quadratmeter
zusammenkommen der unterschied zu dem
tief im juli ist aber dass dieser regen
war eine längere zeit fällt wir erwarten
also keine sturzfluten kleinere bäche
oder flüsse können dennoch über die ufer
treten wir erwarten heute nacht häufig
regenfälle selten bleibt es trocken und
die temperaturen sinken auf 16 bis 7
grad morgen bleibt es kühl bei uns mit
13 bis 18 grad und einzig am bein geht
es wahrscheinlich so auf 19 bis 20 grad
drauf und auch morgen fällt häufig regen
der regen ist zum teil mit gewittern
durchsetzt und chancen auf sonnenschein
haben sie allenfalls im nördlichen
schleswig-holstein westlich des rheins
und am oberrhein und auch in den
nächsten tagen geht es doch sehr
wechselhaft weiter aber mit dem
meteorologischen herbst wird es dann von
westen tatsächlich wärmer sehen sie mal
hier am trend für freiburg im breisgau
uns erwarten in der nächsten woche dann
doch wieder temperaturen zwischen 20 und
25 grad wenn das nicht mal aussichten
sind guten abend